rocket mortgage by clickin loans makes
the complex simple giving you superhero
levels of confidence understand the
details and get approved in as few as
eight minutes so nothing stands in your
way hey everybody its charlie they've
officially started the Avengers infinity
war press tour so just expect more
really weird promos like this which I
think sometimes are more effective than
the actual trailers because people
aren't so worried about spoilers but on
top of that they've started screening
early versions of the film for people
there was one in Mexico so I'll break
that down without any spoilers don't
worry no spoilers in this video like
this is all stuff that we've seen in the
trailer so far the thing about the stuff
that they've been screening early and
they've also confirmed that this is
going to be happening in a couple weeks
when they do their critics screenings
which hopefully I'll get a chance to see
is that they're not going to screen the
entire movie so typically when they do
critic screenings so that people can do
their reviews before the movie comes out
they'll just show them the movie but for
Infinity Ward they're leaving out choice
big spoilery parts what you think
everybody is fine with even though you
know it's kind of hard to do a complete
review even a non-spoilery one without
seeing the entire movie so if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
and it seems like it's right around the
corner but infinity war still just about
three weeks away and I'm still doing
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you
have to do to enter that it'd just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video just to address that new footage
in here the really cool thing about this
is that it actually gives you a better
look at Iron Man's new bleeding-edge
armor they reconfigure the gauntlets so
this is kind of like an Iron Man 2
moment where they get into a really big
Jam and he's like just hold up I got a
really special ability that I'm going to
unlock so just like Goku he goes Super
Saiyan and unlocks some new crazy level
of power but the thing about infinity
war is the way that they've teased this
out is that it's not gonna be enough to
defeat Thanos so like he's just gonna
have a couple of special things that
they'll unlock most of that probably
takes place relatively early in the film
so we know we're gonna get iron spider
that's kind of like his super saiyan
mode Thor gets his new Stormbreaker
weapon everybody sort of has their level
up moment like they come into it being
really power
full characters but not as strong as you
No
you're stronger but then in the way of
all these movie arcs they're not enough
alone
to fight it so they have to come
together level up so that they can beat
him in Avengers for this Hot Toys
replica of Thanos looking like he's
getting ready to smash Captain America
in the face with the completed Infinity
Gauntlet is a good way to talk about it
this might not actually be a scene from
the movie like I tweeted this out just
with a joke the other day people like
wait wait a minute is this a spoiler no
that's not a spoiler hot toys will just
do whatever it can to get you to buy
their really expensive replicas but I
wouldn't be surprised that they cut
stuff like this out of the critic
screenings they're actually getting
ready to do their next one in Edinburgh
so if you live in that part of the UK I
would recommend that you try to get a
ticket but they're probably sold out by
now I almost thought about flying out
there to check it out but it sounds like
they're showing the same 30 minutes of
the film to everybody just to avoid
potential spoilers like if they show two
different 30-minutes everywhere around
the world then if you collectively went
to the internet like reddit or something
like that you could piece together the
entire film so I think they want to
prevent stuff like that by just showing
everybody the same footage so no worries
about spoilers the stuff that they've
shown people interestingly enough is
just the stuff that they put in the
trailers so it's basically two separate
big scenes that are just really extended
remember it's 30 minutes of footage so
they have the scene with everybody at
the sanctum right up to iron spider
nobody's talked about iron spider in any
of the footage they've seen so I'm
guessing they cut right before that
really big moment like we all have
theories about what's going on here you
have a pretty good idea of what's going
on if you've seen the trailers and then
the other scene is just Thor meeting the
Guardians and then deciding what to do
next
we've already seen versions of that in
the trailer so far I'll add a link to
the video that I did for that at the end
of this
what happened
so really what you wind up getting is
like a bunch of different versions of
the same couple of scenes which i think
is fine like they just want to avoid
giant swaths of the film that will be
really spoilery like Thor with his new
weapon the reason why you haven't seen
him with the other Avengers in other
trailer footage is because he's probably
using that weapon in most of the footage
and they're like well we don't want to
show him the weapon yet because this was
really big reveal so we'll just keep all
those parts out of the trailer but turns
out he has that during most of the film
so not a whole lot of Thor in the
trailers the saga of the missing Hawkeye
continues to they actually just sent out
the IMAX poster it's huge it looks
amazing
all the characters are on it there's
even a wee little Ant Man back in the
background here but still no Hawkeye
anywhere the same thing happened when
they released the character posters even
boss logic stepped up and was like
here's the Hawkeye Ronin poster but
obviously it's a fan art there is no
Hawkeye poster the ruse is pretty much
confirmed that he's not big during
infinity war but he's doing big things
behind the scenes he's on a secret
mission so to speak a lot of speculation
if that mission has something to do with
the Infinity stones remember that
they're all coming together during
Avengers 4 so I would be willing to bet
that he's trying to find some critical
piece some person that will help them
out during Avengers 4 because they
killed him off during been disses
Avengers disassembled then Bendis
brought him back for new avengers so he
became a part of that new avengers squad
so I know a lot of people like this
Hawkeye died during infinity war because
he's high on everyone's list well
remember that he was seen on set for
Avengers 4 so he's probably gonna be
fine which is all the more reason not to
make him a really big character during
infinity war like you really want to
feel like any of these characters could
die even though only a couple of them
are probably gonna die I'll do an
updated death predictions list before I
have a chance to see the movie I won't
actually be able to post any kind of
like full review or video till the
embargoes up that's not gonna be
happening till Tuesday April 24th the
movie for most people comes out that
week which is the standard treatment
that Disney gives to its bigger films
like Star Wars stuff that's really big
potentially spoilery and they know is
going to make a lot
money like all the reviews that have
been coming out of these early
screenings have been crazy like
everybody's going nuts for it so I don't
think that anybody's worried about
infinity war being a bad movie they're
more worried about like really spoilery
stuff happening like somebody going
rogue and giving a blow-by-blow of which
characters die and how they die like at
this point it's all still speculation so
it's all still fair game nobody has
actually seen who dies during infinity
war so if you hear spoilers on the
internet in the next week or two they're
probably fake but don't worry when I do
post my review video like the actual
review video I will do non spoilers
right up through the weekend then we'll
start talking about post credits scene
and all the crazy stuff that will lead
into Avengers 4 like I have a pretty
good idea of what my infinity war video
schedule is gonna be like for the next
month or so once we get into May and
everybody has a chance to see the movie
we'll start talking more about Captain
Marvel ant-man and the wasp in Avengers
4 there been a lot of rumors that
Marvel's gonna make a big announcement
for phase 4 on Monday no idea what that
is they might announce one of their new
movies they might tell us when the Black
Widow movie is actually gonna come out
but because they're on their press tour
right now what's gonna start happening
next week the week after that is you'll
start seeing the actors going around
actually doing stuff to promote the film
right now is still kind of quiet as I'm
posting this video but they've started
their press tour meaning that all the
actors are flying all over to different
places in the world to start actually
pushing the film on people eventually as
we get closer to the film coming out
you'll start seeing them do stuff
together like right before Civil War
when they were going on Kimmel every
single night that'll start happening
pretty soon so I'll do videos for
whatever big stuff ends up dropping but
leave all your requests in the comments
below really well the same with you you
get when you can't see your face I guess
the you're not in the costume wouldn't
when the helmet closes I'm getting
shiatsu Joe and Anthony Russo they're
brothers is it when you have two
directors does it make it more difficult
or is it easier well sometimes it's fun
to try to pit them against each other
that's not what your brother said
but if there was any confusion about
what was actually happening at these
early screenings they're just screening
parts of the film for critics
everybody's going crazy for it just like
you would expect so at this point the
only real big surprises that I'm
expecting for infinity war are who's
going to die I don't think there's gonna
be any special Fantastic Four stuff
going on or x-men crossover it's still
too early in the deal between Disney and
Fox for that to happen but don't worry
if there is like a really big rumor that
you guys want me to address just let me
know in the comments - I'm happy to do
videos like that because some of them
are really easy to debunk
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Ghost
please private message me so I can get
your contact details now that they've
actually started selling those infinity
gauntlets the giveaway should start
going out too so if you have been a
giveaway winner since I've started doing
this giveaway just be sure to check your
youtube inbox in the next couple of
weeks because that'll start going out
really soon what you wait for everything
click here for a new spider-man infinity
war and Spider Man ps4 and click here
for brand new Deadpool thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight